the most profound thing about digit
earning products into digital products
from my perspective is that price
becomes arbitrary so in the traditional
world there's a pretty strong
correlation between the cost of a
product to make and the price you can
charge for it you charge some something
that's slightly above the you know the
cost and the more competition is the
less you can charge you tends to drive
prices down to the marginal cost in
digital products where the marginal cost
is zero the price can be anywhere from
zero to infinity it's complete a
complete disconnect between the cost
production and the price the price you
charge what this means is not that
everything goes to serum is that you get
a range you get a much wider dynamic
range of pricing from zero to two to
higher now how is that possible the way
it's possible is that you're you know
you're using free to reach the broadest
possible audience and then you've
segment that audience into different
ability and willingness to pay which
means you're getting different products
so you know you've got flicker and then
you've got flickr pro and what you've
done is you've sort of said here's the
service of utility to all people who
have photographs however your view if
you're really keen if you're a super
enthusiastic photographer some point
you're going to want more space you're
going to want better features etc at
that point we convert you to paid and
because you're so invested in the
servicing because you care so much about
it because you are you are kind of the
Alpha user price is almost you're almost
immaterial to you you value the service
so much do you want to pay almost
anything so you're willing to pay more
then you might have if they had a
one-size-fits-all product it was
designed for everybody that one would
have had to be relatively cheap but if
zero is the way that is the one that
fits everyone and 995 1995 2995 whatever
becomes the one for the segment of
enthusiasts then you can build a good
business where you charge more to some
customers and less for others
what digital allows you to do is to have
a range of prices what digital requires
you to do is have a range of products
which means you know let so take to take
one of the examples that give a lot is
the video game industry which which may
seem trivial but is a fascinating
experiment in watching an industry shift
from silver disks online on their own
terms so the music industry had it sort
of happened to them the software
industry is kind of doing it as it
solves the shifts from disks to software
as a service but the video game industry
is doing it I'm driven by consumer
consumer demand but but yes starting in
China and Korea is doing it to it to
reinvent what they do and as such games
become you know single player to
massively multiplayer they start to
follow the world of warcraft models but
vastly to watch you know them figure out
how as they go online they tend to be
free to play and then to convert five
percent ten percent to paid customers
and one of the best examples is um it
may be familiar to many people watching
is the this Club Penguin Club Penguin is
a game for kids an online game for kids
my kids play it probably many many
people in the audience that their kids
are playing it's free to play owned by
disney bought by i'm not mistaken for
700 million lots hundreds of maine's
free to play I'm but at a certain point
you know your kid is going to want a pet
for their penguin called puffle now to
get a pink puffle for your penguin
you're going to have to subscribe and so
at that point they come to the parents
and they say you know mom dad can I can
I have your credit card or when you get
your credit card out and subscribe for
me what's interesting about this is that
our kids come to us all the time saying
I saw this you know ad on TV can I have
it the answer's no right you know that
you trust me it's not as good as it
looks in the ad you won't play with it
for long you don't really want it and we
it's easy to say no but when the kids
come to kit you and your kid comes to
you and says I've been playing club
penguin for two weeks I built my igloo I
populated the igloo I made these friends
I've done all this stuff now I want more
you know the play utility already
ascertained the value of the kid the
sort of you know the importance in their
life already established you're much
more inclined to pay and they get some
like twenty to thirty percent conversion
rates and what's cool about that once
you're willing once you
to convert on those terms is that you
wanted to pay more and you're you're
more likely to be happy and your turn
rates go down so that is an example of
segmentation within the game they found
all these different ways to charge you
for more in a way that felt totally
natural is like I get it I want more I
hardly mind thing
what free allows you to do free is is me
people in not not everyone's figured
this out but you know the kind of
terrifying reality of free for the
advertising industry is that is an
alternative to advertising rather than
telling people about a product you can
let them try the product and the nice
thing about and and if you're going to
take and try the product you don't have
to take out ads you can just let the
product sell so speak for itself let it
go viral people will recommend a product
that's free because there's no risk to
the people they recommend it to that
they'll that they'll be unhappy using it
at least the way wasted their money so
I'm so the potential there is that free
products can go wide free products you
know can become viral they can end up
marking them marketing themselves and
you can end up converting 10% of a very
big number at very low customer
acquisition costs so that's good however
here's a couple there's a couple
problems I'm first of all you know
there's the what if you convert one
percent or point one percent or point
zero one percent you know at certain
point the conversion rates can be so low
that almost doesn't matter how big your
number is you're still not going to
bring enough people the second point is
that is that yep let's say that your
conversion rate is one percent and you
know anybody's out there being used by
millions of people well those I talked
about near zero marginal cost well
there's a difference between years of a
marginal cost and zero marginal cost
even the product only costs ten cents
per user for you to storage and
bandwidth etc if it's ten cents times
you know 10 million people it starts to
add up to real money so Facebook and
Twitter are two companies that are free
to users they got so popular and so big
that there this tiny marginal cost
started to add up to some very
significant real costs and so they had
to raise hundreds of millions of dollars
to pay now neither of them in their
first form really works hard on that
conversion on making money but they're
now as they're now they have real costs
are starting to do it and you're seeing
a real time experiment in the freemium
you know freemium model of course you
know Facebook may use advertising but
Twitter probably is going to not try to
avoid advertising and go for freemium
models it'll be very interesting to see
what happens what is a one percent
conversion rate
Hey look like a Twitter what is a what
would a five percent conversion rate
look like you know you know a ten
percent conversion rate to Twitter would
be like the best business you could ever
imagine now that in the regular world if
you're selling muffins and got ten
percent conversion rate you're going out
of business but in the digital space a
ten for ten percent conversion rate can
be incredibly lucrative because it's
again ten percent of a very big number